Scott Patterson who you may know better
as l no cell phones Bane actually came
out to surprise us and gave us a little
tour of the yo girl set and of course we
had to sing the theme
[Music]
song we're here today to introduce the
collaboration between Scottie P's big
mug coffee and Warner Brothers and
Warner Brothers Studio Tour and the
Warner Brother Studio store now offering
three blends with the latest drip drip
as and coffee which tasted so good the
coffee is available in light dark and
medium roast get all the coffee you need
it's the best coffee on the planet and
can we talk about how cute this
packaging is he even signed it for nine
and some other fans on tour and I'm so
happy that I get to drink Luke's coffee
in my own home